hi I'm Chet Haase from the Android team
at Google where I work on graphics and
animations and today I wanted to talk a
little bit more about ListView
animations which I talked about in a
previous episode this is another episode
in the series that I like to call you're
doing it wrong so this is another item
related to the last one where there is a
need to understand how views are
actually used by ListView ListView
recycles views which means that when
those views are not on the screen it may
use that view to hold different content
and you need to be aware of that when
especially when you're running
animations so that you're not animating
the wrong thing so to demonstrate that
let's take a look at a little demo so we
have this demo that I call ListView
animations and there's a long list and
quite a boring one of cheeses
now as I click on these items they're
going to automatically fade out and then
be removed from the adapter in the
ListView is going to update itself and
that cheese will no longer exist so we
can scroll someplace we can delete this
one we can see the fade-out and then the
ListView collapses around it so all of
that is good but what happens if we
delete a couple of these and then fling
the list hopefully you can see this on
the screen but what you should be able
to see is as I'm flinging the list there
seemed to be items that have nothing to
do with the ones that I clicked on that
are being removed and this is because
we're running a fade animation on a view
which has since been recycled and is
being used for different content now
that doesn't mean that the wrong item is
being deleted but it does mean that the
wrong view is being animated so what
happens is we click on an item it starts
running a fade animation on it
we fling the list that view is off the
screen it gets reused for a different
content the view continues fading
because it's the same instance it's the
same object inside so it continues
fading even though it now shows
different content and then when that
animation is done then we automatically
delete the original item so the data is
still intact that's fine but the visual
experience on the screen is just weird
right we don't want to do stuff like
that
so there's a couple of ways that you can
account for this and I want to talk
about those today so for one thing you
could use this item called view property
animator and as of jellybean actually
both of these ways of compensating for
this are in the jellybean release one is
to use view property animator which
internally tells the system hey I'm not
done with this view yet so just let me
run my animation in peace so if I'm
using that for the animations and then I
do the fling operation you'll see that
there is no more disruption on the
screen nothing is being faded out in the
new views that are that we're seeing on
the screen because we are persisting the
views that have the animations running
on them so basically we're grabbing it
and saying you know what I have a lock
on this view don't recycle it yet
because I am in the middle of using it
if you don't want to use your property
animator another way to get the same
capability again in the jellybean
release is to use this new property
called transient state so you can call
this method saying set has transient
state and that tells us you're in the
middle of using it and we won't recycle
it until you tell us to so again we
delete some things we fling the list and
we have no disruptive experience on the
screen because we know that you're still
using those views that you are fading
out so interesting demo more interesting
code let's take a look at that so we
have this class called ListView
animations we create the you know the
check boxes in the ListView and the
adapter all that stuff the interesting
part is down here what happens when we
click on an item so when we click on it
we're immediately going to run this
animation but how we run it depends on
which of those check boxes we check at
the top for using view property animator
or transient state or none of those so
in in the none of those case basically
we wind up in this code down here we say
ok I'm going to create an object
animator and we're going to animate in a
previous episode we saw some basics on
how to use object animator we use a
target object we use a target property
we're going to animate the Alpha
property on that view and we're going to
animate 0 from whatever value it has
right now which happens to be one fully
opaque usually is so we create the
animation we set a duration of a
thousand way too long for this operation
but for the purposes of this demo I
wanted you to actually be able to see
the animation and the artifact as it was
happening the transient state is not
checked so we're going to skip this code
here which is the interesting
part which we'll get to later we're
going to add a listener so that we can
actually restore these things later and
then remove it from the data set so on
animation ends so when this nice little
fade animation out to zero ends we're
going to go in here and actually remove
it from the list of cheeses notify the
data set change restore the Alpha
property which is always important to do
with fading animations and then we're
done and then we start the animation so
life is good unless that view got
scrolled off the screen after the
animation started in which case the view
has been reassigned to different content
we get that disruptive experience that
we saw earlier
so the two workarounds for it are to use
a view property animator so if you check
that box at the top of this demo then
instead of using object animator to
animate that view we're going to use
view property animator and we do that by
calling code much like this we say view
dot animate that returns the instance of
the view property animator for that
specific view set duration again we want
an unusually long duration for this
animation just for the purpose of this
demo and then we're going to animate
alpha to a value of 0 from its current
value which happens to be 1 and when
this animation finishes it's going to
have an end action which does something
remarkably similar to what we saw before
it's going to remove the item from the
cheese list notify data set changed and
restore the Alpha property and we're
done no special magic to work around
this instead internally we're doing the
right thing to tell the ListView don't
recycle this view yet because I am in
the middle of using it and then when
that animation is done it unset set flag
and that view can be recycled
appropriately the alternate way to do it
if you're not using view property
animator you can have access to this
exact same functionality by calling set
has transient States so if you check
that other box at the top of the demo
that said transient State
then we will say set trend set has
transient States so when you click on
the item we're automatically going to
flag that item in the list view as
having transient State which means the
ListView will not recycle that item
until you tell it it's ok so we're going
to set as transient state we're going to
run the same exact animation as before
but on animation end is going to run
this little additional bit of code which
we
stores the transient state to its
default state of false so you click on
the item we start running the object
animator it's fading out to view it's
all happy you've set transient state on
it we fling the lists that view still
exists even though it's now off-screen
you can't see it anymore it's not being
used for other content which is really
the key to making this animation
actually work correctly so ListView
animations if you want to do them right
be aware of that transient state and
don't try to animate stuff that's going
to be recycled with other content thanks